ministre j'ordonne au ministre de la
défense
et aux chefs d'états majors de mettre
les forces de dissuasion de l'armée
russe en régime spécial d'alerté au
combat
voilà pour cette annonce donc de
vladimir poutine et pour vous prendre le
pour voir comment ont réagi à ces
annonces côté américain on va tout de
suite prendre la direction de washington
nous attend notre correspondant à
washington justement matthieu mabin
bonjour mathieu mathieu on vient
d'entendre donc l'annnonce de vladimir
poutine qui met en alerte donc les
forces nucléaires russes quelle est la
réaction de la maison blanche à cette
menace nucléaire brandi donc par la
russie de vladimir poutine
oui alors vous l'avez entendu il ne
s'agit pour l'instant que d'une mise en
alerte de la composante nucléaire russe
alors bien sûr dans le contexte que nous
connaissons cette information est prise
très au sérieux par le pentagone et la
maison blanche mais puisqu'il ne s'agit
pas de la formulation d'une menace
directe d'utilisation de ces armes
évidemment la diplomatie américaine se
contente pour le moment d'accuser
réception de l'information ce qu'il faut
lire également en filigrane c'est qu'il
est propre proprement hors de question
pour le département d'état et anthony
blinken de tomber dans le piège évident
entendu ici par moscou en formulant une
réponse prématuré depuis le début de la
crise le département d'état résiste tant
bien que mal à la surenchère
diplomatique pour retarder au maximum la
confrontation militaire alors bien
entendu dès lors que le mot nucléaire
est lâchée il ne faut pas s'attendre de
la part de washington à un changement de
stratégie ce que nous pouvons constater
néanmoins et de l'avis de tous ce que la
capitale américaine compte deux
diplomates concernés c'est que le monde
de fait désormais face à la situation la
plus tendue depuis la crise de cuba au
début des années 60 tout simplement il
n'y a concrètement aucune raison
rationnelle pour que vladimir poutine
brandissent l'armé nucléaire mais ce
qu'il doit raisonnablement nous
préoccuper c'est que la situation
actuelle en ukraine est déjà qualifiée
d' irrationnelles par une majorité de
chancelleries occidentales
mathieu washington la vue est actif
diplomatiquement mais les américains
jouent tina un rôle et ils sont ils
présence sur le terrain militaire en
ukraine
voyez le pentagone n'a jamais fait
mystère il y a des conseillers
américains auprès des troupes régulières
ukrainienne des officiers de l'armée
américaine inséré dans les états-majors
ukrainien dont la fonction est double
d'abord ils ont un rôle de conseil
notamment dans l'utilisation des
systèmes d'armes livrées par les états
unis à l'ukraine mais également des
conseils qui peuvent être d'ordre
tactique ensuite le meilleur moyen pour
le pentagone d'avoir une vision claire
de la situation sur le terrain une
situation qui évolue en permanence vous
le voyez c'est évidemment d'avoir ses
propres hommes au plus près des combats
et enfin dans le domaine du
renseignement un domaine absolument
cruciale en ce moment pour le président
zelensky le pentagone assume absolument
son soutien à l'armée ukrainienne et ce
qu'il s'agisse de renseignements
technologiques par imagerie satellite ou
drones par exemple ou même qu'il
s'agisse de renseignement humain
l'extension de ce renseignement humain
peut se matérialiser sur le terrain par
la mise à disposition de conseiller
technique spécialiste de la guérilla en
clair des agents de la cia un aspect du
conflit qui ne pourra aller qu'en
s'accélérant quand les armées de
vladimir poutine se seront partiellement
ou totalement emparée du pays
merci beaucoup matthieu mabin pour ce
point de vue très complet du coût de la
position américaine depuis washington